It's crazy to think about that
I gave birth to our third baby not even a month ago,
so our afternoons,
evenings, and nights look so much different now.
I always used to think that this phase never ends,
but now I'm just learning to embrace it and find happiness in it.
Today was one of the first hot days this year,
so we decided to go swim in the pool.
The babies have been obsessed with anything that crawls or flies,
so they always need to catch whatever bugs they find.
When dinner time rolled around,
lucky gave the toddlers a bath and got them dressed in pajamas
before we started making some dinner.
Today was a really hectic and hard day,
so we decided on something really simple,
which was just some rice and some ground beef
fried up with some vegetables and avocado.
While I was making dinner,
the kids needed a little snack,
so I peeled some clementines for them just to tie them over.
Lately, I've been cooking really quick dinners,
and this is one of Lucky's favorites.
This point, everyone was really hungry,
so we sat at the table and ate
before heading upstairs and getting the kids all ready for bed
and tucking them in.
I'm usually the one that cooks,
so Lucky's the one that cleans.
That's just how we always do it.
Whoever cooks does not have to clean.
He cleaned the kitchen,
took out the trash,
and then I headed Upstairs to nurse whimsy,
and after that, get in the shower.
I always need to shower at night.
There's never a night that I can
go to bed and unwind without taking a really,
really hot shower.
I like to keep it simple in the shower, and then when I get out,
I lotion my body and do my skin routine.
My eczema has been flaring up really bad lately again,
so I try to use really gentle products on my skin.
I also always slather my face in Vaseline before I go to bed.
At this point, I remembered that I didn't feed my sourdough starter,
so I rushed downstairs and did that
and also took my postnatal vitamins.
Got back upstairs,
got little whimsy ready for bed,
made sure to nurse her,
and then it was my time to unwind,
read my book, and head to bed after.